The simplicity of hitting run and having your app appear on an emulator,
hides a lot of complexity. Remember that Android is a full software stack.
Adspace is a Linux Kernel,
which handles low level tasks like hardware fibers and panel management.
On top of that, are some core C and C plus plus libraries like Libsc and
SQLite and the Android Runtime. That includes cool Android libraries and
the Android virtual machines, Dalvik or more recently ART. Your apps run
within its own instance of the VM using the classes and services provided here
in the application framework. On top of that, sits the application layer,
which includes your app and every other app that's installed on the device. So,
when you hit Run in Android Studio, the first thing that happens is your code
gets compiled into byte code that can be run in the Android Virtual Machine.
That then gets installed onto the device. In Android Studio,
this is done using gradle, a build tool kit that manages dependencies and
allows you to define custom build logic.
You can manually start a gradle build in the IDE by selecting make project.
You can also do this by going to the build menu and selecting make project from
there, or you can use the gradle console to observe any logs or
build errors, or open the gradle tasks window to see any available tasks.
Double clicking on any of them will execute it. This will work from
the command line too. Once you've navigated to the root of your project folder,
you can run gradlew tasks to see all the tasks that you can run. You can learn
more about gradle by checking out the links in the instructor notes. For now,
note that we start with the project, which gradle then builds and
then packages the byte code along with the external resources such as images,
strings, and uixml into an application package. This is called an APK, and
it's a specially formatted zip file. Once you've got your APK ready to go,
it's signed and then pushed to the device using the Android Debug Bridge or
ADB. If we return to the terminal, you can see that ADB let's you interact and
debug apps on any device, physical or virtual. Things like pushing and
pulling files, viewing logcat output, or
even running a remote shell. So once Android's GDO has ADB installed the APK,
it uses ADB again to launch the app by sending a stock command via the remote
shell, by identifying the package and class name of your main activity.